all right it is now uh still 10 minutes
past six do you remember H Mills playing
with Legos some local students take
their Lego skills to extreme levels they
won the state LEGO League Championship
and next it's the world it is the world
they're gonna take it on Candace Jones
joining us live with how you at home can
help them get there and that's so
important Candace good morning good
morning YouTube good morning folks the
mighty Mustang the Lego challenge team
from Joseph M nil steam Academy is
taking the phrase building up your
future to a whole nother level the first
legal leagues introduces science
technology engineering and math or stem
to children ages 4 to 14 through a fun
and exciting world of Legos each team
builds something and creates a
presentation to go with it with a group
of fourth and fifth graders got involved
in the first Lego leagues competition
two years ago last year was a trial run
they didn't place they didn't win but
this year they wanted to go bigger and
better and they did they competed in the
qualifier against 200 teams from Nevada
before for taking first place at the
state competition
most of us were like crying in tears of
joy and stuff and we were like screaming
out loud and we were like we love you
judges
I love that enthusiasm and the mighty
Mustangs have quite the presentation to
show coming up they show me how you take
the Lego first place spots and again
they're on their way to the
international Lego competition in
Massachusetts but you can help them get
there by using this QR code on the
screen to donate now we will have also
details on our website 8newsnow.com for
now live in newsroom I'm Candace Charles
8 news now Candace thank you very much
that money will go to help them build a
Lego plane to fly to the competition
something like that